let's do a hard sideway we're gonna jump  to the uh the big story  Daily Mail says Martha's Vineyard  declares a humanitarian crisis over  influx of just 50 Venezuelan migrants  Republicans slam liberal Island's  pathetic reaction and ask what are the  thousands arriving in Texas every single  day I love this did you guys see Kareem  jean-pierre's response where she's like  it's it's a it's a cruel and unusual  thing to send people to Martha's  Vineyard not like calm down man stop  cracking on Martha's Vineyard dude it's  actually like Ronda santis I'm kind of  jealous like why does he get to give  them a flight to Martha's video what  about me yeah you know no for real like  I I gotta be honest  he could have just randomly chosen 50  Floridians and been like you're getting  a vacation at Martha's Vineyard instead  the illegal immigrants are the ones who  get this luxurious vacation yeah well  look at the immigrants that go to New  York they get a hotel and uh in Times  Square